today we're going to look at the topic
of semantic parsing and this is my
favorite topic
of the class and it's one of my favorite
topics in NLP altogether when I was at
Google my team was responsible for doing
semantic query parsing for Google search
and for the Google assistant so we
applied the semantic parsing techniques
that we're going to look at today to
billions of queries every day and in 40
major languages now I'm at Apple and we
use very similar techniques for query
understanding for Siri so semantic
parsing is highly strategic for Google
and Apple and Amazon and Microsoft and
it's also been a very hot topic in
academic research over the last five or
ten years now semantic parsing is a big
topic it's a complex topic I think more
than any of the other topics that we've
covered it draws on concepts from
linguistics and logic so I can't
possibly do the topic justice in just
the next hour that we have but
fortunately if this topic catches your
interest we have an abundance of
material on the website that can help
you go deeper we have a series of four
code books that introduce a simple
semantic parsing system called sippy cup
Chris has made a few screencasts that
explained the main ideas in very simple
and approachable terms and there's also
this terrific paper that Chris
co-authored with Percy Liang in 2015
that I think conveys the main ideas of
semantic parsing very clearly and very
concisely for today's lecture I think
the best that I can do is first to give
you some high-level motivation for why
this is a problem that you might care
about why this is an interesting and
impactful problem and second to describe
the standard approach to semantic
parsing in very high-level terms so let
me begin by talking a little bit about
the motivation for semantic parsing at
this point in the course you might be
asking yourself wait I thought we were
supposed to be doing natural language
understanding but I still don't know how
to build c-3po I still don't know how to
build a robot that can really understand
me the stuff that we've looked at so far
vector space models of meaning sentiment
analysis relation extraction they seem
to capture aspects of meaning or
fragments of meaning but there's still a
lot that's missing we still don't know
how to generate complete precise
representations of the meanings of full
sentences and there are so many aspects
of meaning that we don't know how to
capture so for example things like
higher arity relations or events with
multiple participants or temporal
aspects like this example Barack and
Michelle Obama got married in 1992 in
Chicago or logical relationships as in
no one may enter the building except
policemen or firefighters as an example
try to imagine building a natural
language understanding system that could
answer logic puzzles like this one this
was actually the very first project that
I worked on when I was a young eager PhD
student became before I became
disillusioned this is a type of logic
puzzle that appears on the LSAT exam and
it used to appear on the GRE exam as
well this is a typical example and this
is basically a constraint satisfaction
problem a CSP so you have six sculptures
which you need to assign to three rooms
while respecting some constraints that
are given there the interesting thing
about this type of puzzle is it's
difficult for humans and it's difficult
for computers but what makes it
difficult is completely different for
humans and for computers for humans
understanding the language is easy and
in fact the authors I guess ETS has
taken great pains to ensure that the
language is clear and unambiguous they
really want to avoid any
misunderstandings where like the human
reader just didn't get it so they work
hard to make the language very clear and
unambiguous for humans the language is
easy but solving csps doing the logic
part of it is hard and that's what this
is supposed to be testing for computers
it's the other way around for computers
solving CSPs
is easy in fact it's trivial for
computers understanding the language is
hard if we could build a model that
would automatically translate this text
into formulas of formal logic then a
theorem prover can do the rest it'll be
completely trivial for a theorem prover
but that translation translating this
into formal logic is far more difficult
than it might at first appear and to
illustrate this I want to take a close
look at just a few specific challenges
that might arise so our challenge is
build a system that can translate these
words into formulas of first-order logic
one challenge is that many words have
semantic idiosyncrasies so an example is
the word same so consider the sentence
sculptures D and G must be exhibited in
the same room if you translate this into
formal logic you're probably gonna get
something like this
so I've glossed over some details here
like I didn't worry about existentially
quantifying variables x and y but i
think it's enough to convey the the
basic idea what this says is if D is in
X so D is a sculpture and X is a room if
D is in room X and G is in room Y then X
and y must be equal to each other okay
so that seems straightforward but the
point I want to make is that this
adjective same is a funny kind of
adjective and to make that clear let me
compare it to some other adjectives
let's instead look at the sentence
sculptures D and G must be exhibited in
the Red Room think about what that
logical form for that would look like it
might look something like this
if it starts off the same way if D is in
X and G is in Y then X is red and Y is
red by the way I'm using sort of a lisp
e lifts like Lisp like syntax here Rev
and standard for store logic syntax but
hopefully it's still under it doesn't
really matter what the syntax is and
hopefully it's still understandable you
might quibble with my logical form here
B
well I didn't properly account for the
semantics of the the definite determiner
which is a very rich topic in itself but
I think that's a issue that we can
safely put to the side it's not really
the main point here the real point is
when I say the Red Room or a Red Room
maybe we'll be better
I'm just certain something about the
rooms that D and G are in I'm saying
whatever room D is in it's got to be a
Red Room and whatever room G is in it's
got to be a Red Room as well and if I
look at other adjectives like if I
change it to large room or smelly room
it's going to have the same kind of
semantics it's gonna be the same mapping
into a logical form does everybody buy
that do these logical forms look more or
less right putting aside issues like the
the definite determiner red and large
and smelly are ordinary adjectives
they're what's called intersective
adjectives they have semantics which are
intersective same is a funny kind of
adjective it's called an anaphoric
adjective and it it that refers to the
to the idea that the semantics of same
refer back to something earlier in the
sentence the same room is not a specific
room or even a room with a specific
quality it's just whatever room D and G
are in if you build it let's say you've
successfully built machinery that can do
semantic interpretation of this sentence
in this sentence in this sentence it can
successfully handle ordinary adjectives
that same machinery is going to break
down when it gets to an adjective like
same which syntactically looks identical
but semantically behaves very
differently and there are other examples
too if you're an eager young PhD student
you might think oh okay I ran into a
problem no worries I'll just fix it I'll
just make my model know about same but
then you realize there are more problems
like that there's other anaphoric
adjectives like different which have
similar properties and you might say
okay why just add another epicycle to my
model
and I can handle that one as well but
then you start to encounter more and
more and more quirky semantic phenomena
that are not anaphoric adjectives but
have other kinds of idiosyncrasies that
you haven't accounted for in in advance
let me give you a different kind of
challenge the challenge of scope
ambiguity and to introduce this I'm
going to use a joke from Groucho Marx
it's not a very good joke but it is a
good example of scope ambiguity it
starts off in this country a woman gives
birth every 15 minutes okay didn't know
that but all right then he continues our
job is to find that woman and stop her
so this joke hinges on a semantic
ambiguity when you read the first part
you're like okay every 15 minutes there
is some woman who gives birth but when
you get to the second part he's giving
that person it's a different reading
instead there is a specific woman who
gives birth every 15 minutes
that's the semantic ambiguity it's a
question of whether the universal
quantifier every where the existential
quantifier takes wider scope because I'm
a language nerd I collect examples of
scope ambiguities that's a perfectly
normal thing to do right and I have
another nice one which has exactly the
same structure children there is a time
and place for everything you can see
again it has the the existential
quantifier and the universal quantifier
so the you know that the standard
reading is for everything there exists
some time in place for that thing but
the alternate reading is there is one
specific time in place which is the time
for everything right and the joke
continues and it is called college this
is from South Park I thought that might
resonate with you guys because you're at
a university so this is that this is
this is the idea of scope ambiguity how
does it relate to the lsat puzzle that I
just showed you well one part of that
LSAT puzzle was this no more than three
sculptures may be exhibited in any room
so this is interesting because there's
not just one possible reading here or
even two possible readings there's at
least three possible readings here which
if you rendered them as first-order
logic are quite different in terms of
their logical form and their logical
consequences but all are plausible
readings of this sentence and from a
computer's perspective there's no way to
know in advance which one is the correct
reading I think the most obvious one the
one that the authors intended you to get
was this one there cannot be a room that
contains more than three sculptures but
there's some other possible readings
here can anybody think of another way of
reading this sentence no more than three
sculptures may be exhibited in any room
that has different that would have a
different logical form that has
different logical consequences yeah
that's how that's not one of the ones I
was thinking of but you're you're
touching on something about whether
we're talking about a single point in
time or over time whether whether the
assignment of sculptures to rooms could
change over time yeah
there cannot be any no more than three
sculptures as long as a person as long
as they was there in a room so it's got
curious in their room yeah you could you
could read this as no more no more than
three sculptures may be exhibited in any
room like it doesn't matter what room it
is no more than three sculptures may be
exhibited at all in any room that
reading of this sentence is maybe a
little bit less obvious and
but less accessible than the first one
but I think there are ways of
contextualizing this that make that
reading plausible yes there are because
in the first one a possible world of
something a possible configuration
that's consistent with the first
sentence is you have two sculptures in
this room and two sculptures in that
room but that is not consistent with the
second reading which says no more than
three maybe maybe exhibited at all yeah
exactly so they have different logical
consequences depending which one you
read third reading which I think is even
harder to get to but I I claim is still
a plausible reading of the first
sentence and that one is at most three
sculptures have the property that they
may be may be exhibited in any room for
other sculptures there are restrictions
on allowable rooms so go back to that
first sentence now no more than three
sculptures meet no more than three
sculptures may be exhibited in any room
the other ones have restrictions right
that's a plausible reading it's not the
most obvious reading but it's a
plausible reading and from the
perspective of a computer algorithm like
computers don't have intuitions about
which one of these things is more
plausible or less plausible
so when you're building a system to map
these sentences into logical forms
you're sentient your model probably
needs to account for all of those
possibilities because in different
contexts any one of them might be the
correct interpretation of course you
also hope that your model will be able
to make good predictions about which one
is more likely and less likely and a
little bit later we'll look at ways of
building a scoring model which will help
you choose among multiple possible
parses multiple interpretations of a
given input I'm not going to say
anything more about the LSAT puzzle but
I could go on there are lots more
challenges I'll just mention one one
other off the top of my head
if you there's nothing in the problem
itself let me go back to that problem
there's nothing in the problem that says
a sculpture can only be in one place at
one time there's nothing that says a
sculpture can't be in two rooms at the
same time but if you just map this into
first sort of logic and then give it to
a theorem prover the theorem prover will
happily put one sculpture in two
different rooms because that's common
sense knowledge that it that a sculpture
can't be in two different places at the
same time a human just fills that in
automatically without even thinking
about it but a computer doesn't know to
do that so you have to if you want to
make this work you have to also supply
all kinds of background knowledge which
is kind of unstated in this problem so
we started this problem you know as I
mentioned at the beginning my PhD and we
worked on it for about like three months
and the further we got into it the more
we realized we're not going to solve
this problem and that was like 15 years
ago and as far as I know this problem
remains unsolved today this is a really
hard challenge but it looks at first
glance like it should be achievable okay
here's a this this is taken from a
consulting project yeah I'm not sure
it's a good intuition though you know a
lot of the constraints that I was
talking about might come from the domain
thank you so he was it a very different
kind of example this is taken from a
consulting project that I worked on when
I was in grad school
and I was working with a startup that
wanted to build a natural language
interface to a travel reservation system
so they wanted to be able to understand
and respond to natural language
descriptions of travel needs like this
the idea is you'd be able to send an
email to this service and they would
automatically figure out some travel
plans for you so what are some of the
challenges to semantic interpretation
that you see here there's lots of them
yeah yeah I mean Oakland but it doesn't
actually make it clear whether Oakland
is an alternative to SFO or an
alternative to Boston now as a human you
know that it's an alternative to SFO it
wouldn't make sense to book a flight
from SFO to Oakland it might be fun but
but an automated system of course you
know that relies on world knowledge
which might not be available to an
automated system what else could make
this hard yeah that's right you have to
resolve some anaphora here and figure
out what that pronoun refers back to and
there's other there's other kinds of
reference resolution here like for
example Sunday evening or Monday morning
we need to figure out that that refers
to the Sunday that presumably that's
refers to the Sunday that follows that
Friday not the Sunday that precedes that
Friday right so I guess we're talking
about Sunday the 14th or Monday the 15th
something else weird here which is that
if Friday is the 12th then Wednesday
can't be the 18th like mathematically
that doesn't work the human that the
Friday and Wednesday or 5 days apart but
the 12th and the 18th or 6 days apart
the human made a mistake and the system
has to deal with it somehow like a
reasonable thing would be for this
system to say did you mean Wednesday the
17th but unless you engineer that into
the system it's not gonna be able to do
it what other challenges do you see here
yeah seems like there's also some
extraneous information like it it's
important that they don't want to fly on
United but it does model probably
doesn't need to care about why that's
right or why the husband is staying
later yep so how to focus on what
matters and what doesn't matter hating
their guts is an idiom so this gives you
a flavor of some of the kinds of things
that you run into when you try to do
complete and precise semantic
interpretation on real-world problems
this goal of cement of complete and
precise natural language understanding
goes way back to the beginning last time
Chris mentioned the shirred lue system
which was developed almost 50 years ago
by Terry Winograd when he was a grad
student at PhD he's now a professor here
and he doesn't work on natural language
understanding anymore but this was
arguably the birthplace of natural
language understanding so sure louisa
blocks its an NL u system that's
grounded in a blocks world it parses the
users input maps it to a logical form
and then tries to interpret that logical
form in its world and answer a question
or take an appropriate action I give a
link to a youtube video here and it's
worth checking out later these slides by
the way are linked from the website and
from there you can find your way to this
YouTube video it's kind of a fun video
to watch and so you can say even quite
complicated things like find a block
which is taller than the one you are
holding and put it into the box and it
understands and it just does the right
thing and at the time people were
totally wowed by this I mean I think
even half a century later this kind of
elicits a
but certainly at that time it really had
people thinking that human level NLU was
just around the corner
but then that excessive optimism
crumbled when later systems later
systems tried to deal with more
realistic situations and with real-world
ambiguity and complexity part of the
reason this was achievable was that was
this very constrained blocks world that
that we were operating with him another
milestone for semantic parsing was the
chat ad system this was developed around
1980 by Fernando Pereira who's now a
research director at Google so this was
basically a natural language interface
to a database of geographical facts so
you could it could answer Geographic
where I what's the capital of France or
how many countries are in Europe or
things like that it was implemented in
Prolog and it was it used a hand-built
grammar and a hand-built lexicon so
there was no machine learning insight it
was just lots and lots of rules that
drove this this semantic interpretation
now here's something astonishing it is
still possible to run chat 80 even
though this code is older than most of
you you can still run it on the Stanford
rice machines and if you want to try it
yourself here's a recipe for getting
started and it's actually really fun to
kick the tires and and try it out and
see what works and what doesn't work in
previous years I've actually taken time
in class to do this live in class which
is kind of fun but it's a little bit
cumbersome and I feel like maybe the
educational value of it isn't worth the
cost so I'm not going to do that this
time but I want to show you some
examples of some queries that that it
can handle so you can ask it like is
there more than one country in each
continent by the way what's the right
let's see how good you guys are at
geography No why not Antarctica and
Australia yeah funny thing is this
system doesn't say it doesn't think that
Australia is a continent it thinks that
Australasia is a continent so the reason
it says and it does say no but the
reason it's
no is because of Antarctica not because
of Australia what country's border
Denmark it's a pretty easy question yeah
except remember it's 1980 West Germany
West German yeah it's yeah kind of kind
of kind of funny to step into the time
machine back to the back to the Cold War
and all that I'll skip the next two but
this this one is really impressive which
country bordering a Mediterranean
bordering the Mediterranean borders a
country that is bordered by a country
whose population exceeds the population
of India chat ad knows how to get this
question right even though it's
incredibly syntactically complex can
anybody get this one
oh no I'll let you go try chat 80 on the
rice machines you can ask chat 80 and
today we'll tell you the answer by the
way one of the things that I that I when
I show this live one of the things that
I get out of it is trying out small
variations so if instead of saying what
country's border Denmark if I said what
countries touch Denmark or what
countries adjoin Denmark it frequently
just says I don't understand you change
one word and it just says I don't
understand because that other word of
that other formulation that other way of
asking the question just wasn't in the
hand-built grammar the last example kind
of falls in the same bucket how far is
London from Paris it feels like a
question that has very similar flavor to
all the other questions just another
geographical question but it turns out
that no matter how you ask this question
chat ad just says I don't understand it
doesn't know about distances between it
knows about like areas it will tell you
how many square miles you know the total
area of countries south of the equator
and not in Australasia but it can't tell
you about distances between places so it
has two pretty profound limitations one
is that it is it only knows about
certain things it's certainly restricted
to geography even within geography it
only knows about certain kinds of
Geographic facts
that's one restriction the other
restriction is on the phrasing the
allowable phrasing of questions even
questions that it knows the answer to
you have to express your question in a
certain specific way maybe maybe there
are a few different ways that it can
handle but there are lots of other ways
that to a human are perfectly reasonable
way is to ask that the system just can't
handle so on the one hand systems like
sure Lou and
80r pretty astonishing because long
before most of you guys were even born
these systems demonstrated precise and
complete understanding of even quite
complex sentences and by the way they
did it while running on hardware that's
less powerful than you know my rice
cooker admittedly I have a really fancy
rice cooker so it's it's kind of
impressive what they were able to do but
their coverage was extremely narrow it
was limited to one specific domain and
even within that domain they were very
brittle if you ask a question this way
you get an answer if you use just
slightly different words nothing today
by contrast we have systems that exhibit
vastly greater robustness and with very
broad coverage but with very fuzzy and
partial understanding so you can ask
Google about just about anything and it
never says I don't understand but it
might not exactly ask your it might not
exactly answer your question if you
asked Google this question about what
country which country bordering the
Mediterranean borders the country that
is bordered by a country whose
population exceeds the population of
India Google is not going to tell you
the answer or actually what it probably
will do is it'll link you to my slides
from last year which maybe have the
answer but it doesn't have that complete
precise understanding that's needed to
actually answer the question where we
want to be is up here with c-3po and the
pot of gold we want to build systems
that can understand precisely and
completely and robustly over broad
domains now you might not feel super
inspired by examples like that that one
what's the population of the largest
kind of that that one because let's be
honest who cares but the ability to
answer these highly structured kind of
database EE type of queries has lots of
applications that are more compelling so
for example if you're a policy analyst
working on global warming
you want to be able to answer questions
like these and it's easy to imagine that
you have a database that contains all
kinds of statistics about carbon
emissions but unless you're a programmer
you probably don't know how to write
sequel queries to pull out the
information that you need so it will be
great to have a system where you could
just type in questions like this and get
the answer here's another example if you
grew up in America there's a good chance
that you have an uncle Barney who is a
total freak about baseball trivia uncle
Barney would love to be able to ask
questions like these but again he
doesn't know how to write database
queries but if you can invent a semantic
parsing system maybe you can make a
website and sell subscriptions and uncle
Barney will pay you 10 bucks a month and
here's an application that has become
very important at Google and Apple and
Amazon voice commands for getting things
done one thing to notice here is that
these queries are not well served by a
conventional keyword based search just
imagine if you ask Google how do I get
to the Ferry Building by bike and Google
responded by showing web pages
containing those terms that would be a
disappointment because you don't want
web pages containing those terms you
want a map with a blue line on it and
the only way we can draw that map is if
we know where you are and we compute a
route a route from where you are to the
Ferry Building and doing that requires
understanding your intent in a complete
and precise way so satisfying quarters
like these requires mapping them into
structured machine readable
representations of meaning that we can
pass to a downstream component to take
to take action on it requires semantic
parsing so the goal of semantic parsing
is to do precise complete interpretation
of linguistic inputs and to map those
inputs into structured machine readable
representations of meaning so a really
important question is what kind of
semantic representation are we aiming at
what's our target output and there are a
lot of different possibilities kind of
depending on what
the problem is and what the domain is if
the goal is to facilitate data
exploration and analysis then the right
semantic representation might be a
database query language like sequel for
a robot control application you might
want a custom-designed procedural
language for interpreting voice commands
you can often get away with a relatively
simple meaning representation which is
based around a fixed set of high-level
intents that are parameterised by
specific arguments so for example if the
query is directions to SF by train the
semantic representation might be
something that first indicates that this
is a travel query so that's kind of
indicating the intent here the type of
intent and then with two parameters one
is a destination parameter and the value
there is a freebase ID which is the
freebase ID for San Francisco and then
the second parameter describes the
transportation mode and here the value
is I guess any number there's maybe like
five different transportation modes and
transit is one of them and so this
little machine readable expression
conveys everything that you need to pass
to a back-end system which can actually
like figure out the directions and draw
a map and give it to the user and
similarly for other kinds of other kinds
of queries here okay so to illustrate
the central ideas of semantic parsing
we've created a simple semantic parser
called sippy-cup although it's designed
for simplicity and readability it uses
methods that are commonly used at Google
and Apple for semantic interpretation of
user queries and we produced a series of
four code books that introduced
sippy-cup
so unit 0 is kind of a high-level
overview of semantic parsing and then
the remaining units demonstrate the
application of pacifica to three
different problem domains so unit 1
focuses on the domain of natural
language
check this is queries like two times
three plus four as English words rather
than mathematical symbols unit two
focuses on the domain of travel queries
so this is queries like driving
directions to Williamsburg Virginia
which has pretty obvious applications
for assistant products like Google
assistant and Alexa and Siri and then
finally unit three focuses on
geographical queries so things like how
many states ordered the largest date and
this has a very similar flavor to the
kinds of queries that chat ad takes on
so unit three kind of illustrates a
modern machine learning based approach
to the same problem that the chat ad
system took on by the way this approach
that's that sippy-cup
illustrates was pioneered first by luke
zettlemoyer and his group at u-dub and
later by personally young in his group
here at stanford and so the key elements
of this approach are first a
context-free grammar which defines the
possible syntactic structures for the
queries second semantic attachments to
the CFG rules which enable bottom-up
semantic interpretation third a
log-linear scoring model for which is
learned from training data fourth phrase
annotators for recognizing names of
people locations dates times and so on
and finally grammar induction inducing
grammars from training data in order to
quickly scale into new domains and new
languages and over the following slides
I'll talk about each of these five
elements in turn so let's start with the
grammar the grammar is the core of the
semantic parsing system and it has two
parts it has a syntactic a syntactic
part and a semantic part the syntactic
part is a fairly conventional
context-free grammar so we have
terminals like Google and NY and me and
bike and car and then we have non
terminals which we indicate with the
dollar sign
so like dollar look for example is a
non-terminal and
we also use we have a designated start
symbol which here were by convention
we're calling dollar route so every
derivation has to has to bottom out with
a dollar route we're also using a
notational convenience here this
question mark indicates that this
element is optional and so that's just a
notational convenience if I wanted to
avoid using this I could instead have
two rules here one that has dollar route
and all this stuff without the
parentheses in the question mark and
another rule which has dollar route and
all this stuff
except that so this is just saying this
could be here or it could not be here
it's optional so this particular grammar
fragment could be used to parse just a
handful of queries it could be used to
parse route me to New York by car it's
one possible thing that can match this
grammar or it could match route I'll
skip this to let me do a compound
location Google in New York by bike or a
handful of other queries there's not
very many queries which matched this
very limited fragment but it gives you a
flavor of the kinds of things that are
that are that are achievable as is
typical for grammars of natural language
these grammars are usually
non-deterministic so if you've looked at
CF G's in the context of programming
languages like if you took CS 143 you're
probably there you probably have seen
deterministic grammars where there's
only one possible parse one possible
interpretation for any given input in
linguistics we typically deal with
non-deterministic grammars where there
are multiple possible parses for a given
input and that's important because
natural language utterances are very
often I daresay usually ambiguous so
here's an example of a parse for the
input
me to Google in New York by car we
recognize me as an optional word we
recognize Google as a dollar look a
location I recognize in New York as a
dollar look we then recognize Lok in Lok
as a compound Lok we recognize bike as a
dollar mode and then because we've got a
destination and a mode we can use that
last rule to put the whole thing
together into a dollar route which is
the the finals syntactic production
farthing so this is basically the
syntactic parsing tactic parse for that
input so far so good so this is the
syntactic part of the grammar okay so
given a grammar and an input query we
can generate all possible parses of the
query using dynamic programming and
specifically we use an adaptation of the
well-known CY k-chart parsing algorithm
so if you've ever looked at syntactic
parsing before you may have seen you may
have seen this here's how it works the
first thing we do is we rewrite the
grammar so that all of the rules in the
grammar are binary or maybe unary binary
means they only have two things on the
right-hand side what we don't want to
have is three or four or five things on
the right-hand side we want to have at
most two things on the right-hand side
and then what we do is we consider every
span of tokens every sub span of the
whole query and we do that bottom-up so
we work our way up from very small spans
like spans of 1 up to larger and larger
spans as we go for every span we
consider alway always of splitting that
span into two parts and then we consider
every grammar rule whose right hand side
can match those two parts and that's why
it's important to make the grammar
binary so that we only have to consider
splitting things in two and not
splitting things into three or four or
five
every time we have a grammar rule that
matches that can potentially match that
right hand side that tells us that we
have a way of making the category which
is on the left hand side of the rule and
so we can record that as a possible
interpretation a possible parse for that
span and that can be helpful as we work
our way up to larger and larger spans
because it can help us build bigger
things above that we can use those
categories in trying to interpret larger
spans okay so that's the syntax what
about the semantic part of the grammar
every rule in the CFG can come with
what's known as a semantic attachment
and I've shown the semantic attachments
here in the square brackets in green you
can think of these semantic attachments
as little programs that are run when the
parser applies the corresponding syntax
rule and their outputs are fragments of
our meaning representation they
basically these semantic attachments
basically specify how to construct the
semantics for the thing on the left-hand
side from the semantics for the things
on the right-hand side so for google
this one is very straightforward the
semantics for Google is just going to be
a freebase ID which means Google it's
the entity Google similarly for New York
for dollar look in dollar Lok this thing
says the way to construct the semantics
for this dollar Lok is to build it up
out of the semantics for this dollar Lok
and this don't look if you've already
got semantics for this dollar look and
this don't look I'm gonna call the first
one dollar one and the second one dollar
two and this thing says just take the
semantics for this dollar load and the
semantics for that dollar Lok and stuff
it into one of these s expressions with
an in in the front it's a fragment of
our of our meaning representation and
this thing tells us how to build up
these pieces into larger and larger
pieces
these ones are straightforward the
semantics of a dollar mode is just I
want to be
in um values and then the last thing
that's interesting is that this one
tells us how to build the semantics for
the entire request it says it's a get
directions request I guess that comes
from the fact that it's a route the
destination is going to be whatever the
semantics is for this non-terminal and
the mode is going to be whatever the
semantics is for this non-terminal
so these semantic attachments tell me
exactly how to construct my semantic
representation from smaller pieces
building up to larger and larger pieces
so here's our example parse again but
this time I've added in green the
semantic yield associated with each node
in the parse tree by the way if you're a
linguist this is basically Montague
semantics
it's bottom-up syntax driven semantic
construction so first we construct the
semantics for Google and for New York as
freebase IDs and for a bike as an enum
value then we combine these two to get
the semantics for the compound location
up there and finally we combine
everything to get the semantics for the
get directions request at the top okay
let me pause there because that was a
lot to absorb any questions so far okay
let me keep going so the next question
is how do we recognize nicknames and
dates and numbers and things like that
we could do it all in the grammar and
that's just what I did with Google and
New York here I have directly in my
grammar something that associates the
string Google with the semantics which
is a freebase ID and I could do that for
a long long lists of entities and I
could also do it for dates and numbers
and things like that
but if I do that it's gonna mean
lots and lots like millions of rules to
my grammar which is going to be really
messy and cumbersome and brittle and
difficult to maintain and it's gonna
have limited coverage
anyways I mean I can't possibly put
every possible date or every possible
number into my grammar so instead what
we're gonna do is leverage
special-purpose annotators for phrases
that describe entities locations names
numbers dates times and things like that
so here's an example the the example
query is reserved Gary Danko with Tom
next Friday
and so here imagining that we have three
different annotators that are going to
help us interpret this query and they
basically function like black boxes
which run first before the syntactic
machinery gets to work and can hand
their results to the syntactic machinery
so first I imagine that I have a
freebase annotator and this thing its
job is to look for entity mentions that
are things that freebase knows about and
it recognizes this phrase this string
Gary Danko and it says oh I know about
that that's freebase entity this thing
and it tells me this is a dollar
restaurant which I think it figured out
from it it is also able to generate lots
of metadata because it has all of
freebase at its disposal right it knows
about freebase and so it's able to look
this thing up and figure out it's a
restaurant and it knows to generate that
syntactic category and then it also
generates this helpful metadata that can
be passed downstream so for example it
has a confidence score that says ouch
how sure it is that it made the right
interpretation here and that confidence
score can be passed through and and be
an input to scoring the interpretation
later on I also imagine that we have a
contact annotator which recognizes this
this string Tom and it says oh Tom I
know who that is
it's this user ID and he has this email
so obviously the only way that can work
is if the con
TEKT annotator knows who issued the
request it knows that this request is
from a specific user and that user has a
friend named Tom and this is his user ID
so it needs access to some personal
information in order to ground the
semantics with a specific user ID and
finally a date annotator it recognizes
this phrase next Friday and it says oh I
know how to generate semantics for that
next Friday means May 10th 2019 and it
was able to do that because it knows
when the query was issued and therefore
is able to interpret next Friday
appropriately so next Friday is an
indexical expression but to ground it
correctly I need to know something about
where the when the query came from so we
have these annotators that can run
essentially as blackbox modules run over
the input query generate hypotheses
about how to interpret small spans and
record those hypotheses as inputs to the
syntactic machinery that will will will
get rolling afterwards okay a pervasive
problem yes yeah what exactly is the
issue when you first pitched sort of the
problem I have a solution could be to
effect the annotation itself so rather
than saying location goes to New York
you could say location goes to spin and
then the location we both look up on the
span rather than running the entity
recognition first you could run the
semantic parser anyone I gotta find a
span and then pass it to the annotator
is there a reason why I'm further on the
interview first I think maybe what
you're suggesting is that the parsing
could happen top down instead of bottom
up does that sound right it could be
yeah
and that's conceptually that's
definitely possible and like when you
for example if you've taken CS 143 you
study lots of different approaches to
parsing and some of them are bottom-up
and some of them are
hop down and some of them are a mix of
both and all of them are conceptually
possible but there can be big
differences as far as the efficiency of
parsing and particularly for natural
language which is so highly ambiguous
top-down parsing turns out to be
prohibitively expensive and bottom-up
parsing is way more efficient because
you can eliminate unlikely possibilities
early in the process when I was working
on this problem at Google the grammars
that we were working with it was
commonplace for even very pedestrian
inputs to have literally thousands of
possible parses in fact that's the next
point I'm gonna turn to his ambiguity
and when there are thousands of possible
parses you need to do pruning fairly
early in the in the process we we would
use what's called a beam search to
basically maintain and as as the the
process of parsing is happening to
maintain a finite length list of the
most promising possibilities and
aggressively prune beyond that list and
that was the only way to keep the search
for a plausible parse manageable yeah
yeah so this problem of ambiguity is
this is a problem that's that's
pervasive throughout language and
certainly a big challenge for semantic
parsing and ambiguity can include both
syntactic ambiguity and semantic
ambiguity so here's an example the input
is mission bicycle directions so imagine
the user issues this query to Siri or to
the Google assistant one possible
interpretation for that is that we want
to get to the mission
by bike I want mission bicycle direct I
want to buy sit I want to bribe my bike
to the mission that's certainly a
possible interpretation it turns out
that there's a bike shop called mission
bicycle so another possible
interpretation is I want directions to
mission bicycle and I'm not specifying a
transportation mode I just want
direction maybe it's maybe I want
driving directions but where I want to
go is mission bicycle so here I show
these two different parses for this
query in this one mission is a location
bicycle is a mode in this one mission
bicycle is the location and I'm not
specifying a mode in this case in this
example there's only two possible parses
but as I mentioned a moment ago in
complex domains it's with rich grammars
it's commonplace that there are tens or
hundreds or even thousands of possible
parses so if our grammar supports
multiple interpretations how do we know
which one to choose the answer is with a
scoring function we need a way to score
the different candidates so that we can
figure out which one is the most
plausible and one approach to doing that
is with a log linear model to score
alternative derivations so a little bit
of terminology here I'm going to call
the input that is the the query the
natural language query X I'm gonna call
the derivation or parse so that's the
syntactic parse tree with all of its
semantic attachments I'm going to call
that Z and I'm gonna call I'm gonna use
Y to designate the semantic yield so
that means the final semantics it's
basically the semantics that you get at
the root node in the parse tree by the
way Z completely determines Y but for
any given X you may have lots of
candidates Z's and correspondingly lots
of candidate Y's so to build this
scoring function what we're going to do
is first define a feature representation
which captures the key characteristics
of the input X the candidate parse Z and
the candidate semantics Y there's a lot
of room for variation in the future
representation but just to give you a
flavor of like some
commonly used features your feature
representation might include an
indicator function which is one
just in case the input contains the word
two and the candidate semantics contains
a destination parameter presumably like
intuitively makes sense those two things
are likely to go together and so seeing
those together might count as weak
evidence it's hardly proof but it might
count as weak evidence that this is
actually a good parse or you might have
features which capture again indicator
feature so boolean features which
capture the occurrence of specific CFG
rules or specific categories the the
dollar the dollar things in the
candidate parse the intuition here is
some rules in your grammar might be much
more likely or unlikely than others to
participate in good parses invalid
parses you might not be able to
anticipate that in advance but if you
have features like these then you have
the opportunity to learn that from data
you can learn from your data that some
rules work much better than others
another kind of feature you might
include is features which pass through
the confidence score that you got from
an annotator
presumably if the annotator is really
confident that makes it more plausible
that a parse that includes that
annotation is a good parse there's lots
of room for variation in the feature
representation but once you have a
feature representation the score for a
derivation the score for a parse Z will
just be the dot product of the feature
vector and a weight vector theta which
is learned from training data and once
you have a score you can turn the score
into a probability in the usual way by
using the softmax function so the next
question is where do we get this thing
from where do we get the weight vector
theta this is basically the parameters
of our scoring model what we're going to
get it from data we're going to estimate
those model parameters from training
data and we can do it using a variant of
the e/m algorithm the reason for using
the e/m algorithm is that our training
data consists of pairs of inputs x and
target semantics y but the training data
doesn't include the correct parse tree
is Z so there could be multiple parse
trees that yield the same semantics so
we have to treat those Z's as latent
variables and that's what the EML got
let me just go to yeah yeah
I'll try to explain it in application to
the to this specific application the e/m
algorithm alternates between Estep and
m-step yep stands for expectation
maximization and in the estep what we do
here is use the current model parameters
theta to parse the inputs in our
training data and for each input x
generate an n best list of possible
parses so we're just parsing all the
inputs using our current model then in
the end step we're going to change the
weights of the model and specifically we
change the weights to put more
probability mass on the elements of the
N best list that actually generated the
correct semantics in the MS list some of
them are gonna have good the semantics
which match the target some of them will
not and we want to shift the probability
mass towards the ones that match the
target semantics and then we go back to
the e step and do it again we re parse
everything using our updated weights
that could cause the N best list to
shift around and we keep doing that back
and forth between the east opinions and
the m-step so these updates to the
models are basically st
the updates this is kind of like a
stochastic gradient descent algorithm
and the weights will adjust gradually
over time toward weights that are more
and more successful in generating the
target parses for our training data okay
so we've got a grammar
it's got syntax rules it's got semantic
attachments there's ambiguity we have a
scoring function we've learned the
scoring function from data the next
question is where do the grammar rules
come from if and the answer really
depends on what domain you're working in
if it's a small simple domain then
grammars with a few dozen or a few
hundred rules are commonly enough and
that's good at that scale it's practical
to write grammars manually you just like
think about the domain and look at lots
of example queries and just manually
generate some rules that will capture
that we'll cover the the set of input in
the set of inputs properly but that's
not the common situation the common
situation is you're in a large complex
domain and you need thousands of rules
to model the domain well and at that
scale it's just not feasible to write
down all the rules manually so instead
we want to learn the rules automatically
from from training data and this is the
challenge of grammar induction and it's
where some of the most interesting
research work lies one strategy for
grammar induction which it's a very
simplistic strategy but it's illustrated
in unit 1 of the sippy cup code books
the idea is simply to generate all
possible rules and add them to your
grammar and then to use standard
parameter learning to learn weights for
each world to learn which rules are most
likely to contribute to a successful
parse so all what is the first what is
all possible rules mean it basically
means all ways of combining the sin
of your semantic representation your
sort of semantics let your language of
formal semantics always of combining
those symbols into syntax rules every
possible right-hand side every possible
left-hand side the cross-product of all
those things and if we add all those
rules to our grammar then we can
generate a huge variety of different
parses most of them are bad but we can
use the the weight learning that I
talked about on the previous slide to
learn from data which ones are good and
which ones are bad this works but it
comes at a heavy cost because generating
all possible rules leads to an
exponential blow-up in the number of
possible parses and consequently in the
time that's required for parsing and if
you work your way through sippy-cup unit
1 you'll see this Illustrated very
vividly
so more sophisticated approaches to
grammar induction look for ways to be
far more selective about introducing new
grammar rules and also ways to prune
them aggressively when they're not
contributing to successful parses to
keep the size of the grammar manageable
so that training can still run in a
feasible amount of time so we've talked
about two different ways of using
training data in this process one way of
using training data is to induce rules
of the grammar to figure out which
syntactic productions should be part of
the grammar the other way of using data
is to estimate the parameters of our
linear scoring model and these two to
wait two ways of using data are both
really important and kind of work
hand-in-hand so this kind of underscores
the importance of data for making this
whole thing work you can't do grammar
reduction and you can't learn the
parameters of your scoring model without
training data and not just a little bit
of data to really make this work you
want mass
of amounts of data so organizations that
are doing this at scale like Google and
Apple invest a lot of money in data
annotation using proprietary crowd
sourcing platforms similar to Mechanical
Turk so paying greater is paying human
annotators to look at example input
queries and write down the target
semantics for those queries so that we
can then train train machine learning
systems to to capture that however
that's really expensive labeling
examples with target target semantics is
slow and laborious and costs a lot of
money so another really productive
direction has been to enable learning
from indirect supervision an idea Pyatt
pioneered by percy liang is the idea of
learning from denotations
so the notation basically means if
you're semantic representation is
something that can be executed or
evaluated in some way that execution or
evaluation could result in something
that's a lot simpler and more intuitive
for a human annotator to produce so an
example here I should have put an
example on the slide an example might be
like you know what's the capital of the
largest state in the United States the
semantics for that might be some kind of
complex logical formula that literally
says except in logical language instead
of English what is the capital of the
largest state the denotation of that
semantics would be the answer to the
question like Austin you know judo yes I
guess if we're talking about large in
terms of area right what is the capital
of the largest state Juneau Alaska so
that's the denotation if your training
data consists of inputs like what is the
capital of the largest state paired with
logical forms we can learn very
effectively from that but it's hard to
produce that training data because it's
hard to get human annotator
to produce those logical forms and at
Google and Apple we figured out all
kinds of tricks to make that a little
bit easier for ordinary people to
produce logical forms but it's an
intrinsically hard problem it's much
easier to get ordinary human annotators
to produce the answers like Juno and so
if we can have training data that says
what's the capital large estate Juno if
we can figure out a way to learn from
that kind of data we'll be able to get
lots more data and and the benefit of
learning from that data so that's the
idea of learning from denotations this
is a really powerful idea and it's
Illustrated again in unit 1 of sippy-cup
where the domain is natural language
arithmetic so they're the donations are
just the answer to a simple arithmetic
or computation ok so to recap the key
ingredients of this approach to semantic
parsing are CFG s with semantic
attachments log-linear scoring models
annotators grammar induction and above
all lots and lots of training data I
think I hope that that's enough of a
high level overview that if this topic
interests you you'll be able to dive in
to the sippy cup code books start
reading some papers and get a much more
concrete sense of how all this stuff
fits together and how all of this works
but I think I'll stop there for today